peu mais qu'est ce que c'est
m
mais qu'est ce que c'est
le maillot de bain un bronzage intégral
est-ce que ça bronze
ah oui ça peut très bien ça fait un peu
plus de trois semaines que l'on parle de
ces familles au samu maillot de bain qui
permet de compenser intégralement alors
de quoi s'agit-il exactement
bien alors c'est un maillot qui est fait
au voile de coton qui est traitée ou
travailler de manière un peu particulier
pour laisser passer des radiations pour
prendre à travers mais pour ne pas
laisser passer le regard alors vous
voyez que c'est fait dans un tissu glace
demain ce mec parfaitement décent est
très jolie d'ailleurs dans son aspect
alors lorsque ces charmantes jeunes
filles se baigne c'est toujours aussi
peu transparente et en ce moment là et
on peut très bien aller dans l'eau avec
aucun problème ce maillot reste
exactement comme il est maintenant
et cette expérience car il s'agit en
fait d'une expérience va se poursuivre
pendant quelques jours encore et sous le
contrôle d'un huissier s'il vous plaît
pour notre part nous avons été chargés
de nous assurer des bienfaits de ce
maillot mais il nous est impossible de
nous prononcer n'ayant pu constater de
visu ce qu'il en était exactement
[Musique]
alors nous nous sommes renseignés auprès
des intéressés elle mêle pourquoi
voulez-vous bon c'est intégralement
ça fait beaucoup plaisir de garder le
souvenir des vacances ou de la nuit par
exemple
oui vous n'avez pas gardé les marques
n'ont pas du tout les mac c'est ça ce
que je préfère tout ça c'est bien
effectivement c'est de passer les rayons
du soleil ça me plaît parce que vous
avez déjà constater les résultats
oui cet après midi on est restés au
soleil assez longtemps et j'ai pas de
marque sa partie supérieure de la
poitrine et j'ai l'impression que ça
mais il ya une autre solution pour
bronzer intégralement
oui il faut aller en femme blonde
l'autre jour on était toujours suivie
par exemple de par les gendarmes
et maintenant on est plus tranquille
maintenant vous rester dans les normes
de la décence tout l'huissier chargé de
la délicate mission de vérifier la
couleur des petits bouts de peau
judicieusement cachés sous les maillots
s'est acquitté avec le plus grand
sérieux de sa tâche
mais à la déception générale il s'est
refusé à en communiquer les résultats
précisant qu'il rendra publiques ses
conclusions de manhattan
e
[Musique]
et c'est ainsi que l'on fait naître des
vocations d'huissier
[Musique]